now the government's uh today confirmed
plans to put thousands of Asylum seekers
in disused military bases the
immigration Minister Robert genre told
the house of confidence today that
migrants will be housed at former ref
sites this is despite legal threats from
local conservatives we're joining me now
to discuss the government's proposed
plans as shallow Home Secretary Yvette
Cooper
um Ms Cooper good to see you guys thank
you so much for coming on to talk about
this um you made it clear that you said
that you don't think this plan is
workable why
I think the problem is that this
announcement today is an admission of
failure these new plans are in addition
to the costly Hotel use they don't cut
Hotel use they're not an alternative and
the reason for all of that is because at
the heart of this is the home office's
failure to take decisions their Asylum
decision making has dropped by 40
percent and the shocking fact is that 98
of the small boat arrivals last year
haven't actually been decided unless
they get a grip of their decision making
unless they clear the backlog and we
have set out proposals to do that with
Fast Track decision making but unless
they do that this problem is just going
to keep getting worse yeah you say these
plans are in addition to not instead of
hotels but Robert generic himself
admitted that you know they won't end
the use of hotels overnight this is just
the start and what do you make of the
ethics of this because Robert genre also
said that you know the accommodation
that they're going to provide for
migrants this new alternative
accommodation things like RAF basis
shemit essential living standards and
nothing more the UK doesn't want to be a
magnet for displaced people or those
seeking better economic prospects it
will be very much a deterrent in the
government's eyes so what do you make of
the ethics of what they're doing here
well I think the problem is that the
government's lost a grip of the whole
thing so they're not taking the proper
action that we need and that we've
called for to go after the criminal
gangs and to stop dangerous Crossings in
the first place and they voted against
that in fact yesterday they're also not
taking the action that we need to clear
the backlog and make sure that you've
got fast decision making so that you
don't have so many people in this really
costly Hotel accommodation we do think
ministers should have been working with
local councils for years on better value
lower cost and more appropriate Asylum
accommodation but frankly they didn't do
that and that's why they ended up with
this Panic buying of Hotel accommodation
and that is going to continue under
these plans and that's the really
important thing because you know all of
the Flim Flam and all of the headlines
and all of the stuff about barges that
don't exist we've had it time and time
again from this government you get the
headlines and then when you look at the
detail underneath it actually what it
means is just carry carrying on with the
same failed system they're not changing
it they're not replacing it they're
carrying on with the same problems that
we've got at the moment and that means
you end up with this huge long backlog
with continuing boats arriving putting
lives at risk and also undermining our
border security that's why labor set out
an alternative plan yeah the immigration
Minister Robert generic did say that
there would be new funding for local
authorities to help with this let's cut
as you put it the Flim Flam and talk
about Labor's alternative plans it is a
mess someone's gonna have to clean it up
it might be on it might fall to labor
um how would you do it what tell us how
you would do that what is the
alternative plan what's different from
what the government are proposing
when labor set out a five-point plan to
prevent these dangerous Boat Crossings
that are undermining our border security
and also putting lives at risk as well
first we have to go after the criminal
gangs with a new cross-border police
unit secondly you have to get a new
agreement with France on both returns
and things like family reunion we've
also got to clear the backlog we would
have a fast track system for safe
countries like Albania fast tracking
decisions and returns both you've got to
have a reform of resettlement schemes
which are not preventing people being
exploited and then finally you have to
Target some of the crises and some of
the problems at heart in the region and
to support refugees in the region as
well that's the bigger picture isn't it
let's talk about the practicalities of
the situation because you know it's
estimated there are 51 000 people in
hotels currently in around
395 400 hotels
um surely moving them to cheaper
accommodation is a good thing on that
practical issue of housing these people
more cost effectively what would labor
do
well we want to end Hotel use the
fastest way that to do that is to clear
the backlog and we've set out proposals
for a fast track Asylum decision making
but how fast is that going to be
overnight I'm trying to think of where
these people are going to go if we're
spending 6.2 million a day on hotels
where would they go sure let me finish
the point so the first thing is you have
to clear the backlog because if you
don't this is just sticking plasters and
it's going to get worse and worse and if
you fast-tracked cases for a
particularly for safe countries like
Albania the government's still refusing
to do that 12 000 people arrived from
Albania last year and those cases only
one percent of those cases are being
decided so clear those cases really
quickly and get proper decisions proper
returns and so on in place then secondly
we should have the government should be
working with local councils to properly
plan cheaper less costly more
appropriate
accommodation and not have this costly
Hotel use so we are very clear that you
need to end the hotel use because it is
inappropriate and an independent report
came out just today showing that the
home office has completely failed to
manage any of those contracts in fact
it's actually the home office bits of
the home office have been competing with
each other to push those hotel costs I
am going to push you on the
accommodation point because you are
pushing back on the government really
hard on this as I said estimated 6.2
million pounds a day you can move the
backlog as fast as you like it might
still take a couple of weeks that's
running into the the tens of millions if
it's not hotel if it's not a disused RAF
Barracks or a ferry what is it for labor
what is that cheaper accommodation that
local authorities are going to come up
with
so they should be working on alternative
sites and there may be all kinds of
sites that are appropriate but the
moment the government's not doing that
they're not working with local councils
have you been talking to them and also
but be clear but be clear and we have
yes we have heard from different
councils who have different views on
what sort of approach is appropriate but
I would also say that the government is
not moving people out of hotels this is
a myth the homes the immigration
Minister had to admit that today he's
not moving people out of hotels this is
all in addition to hotels because
they're failing to clear the background
but maybe they're not moving around
hotels this other accommodation that you
keep talking about you can't you can't
name me anything and it's you know sorry
to keep them to you but yeah
it is really important because there is
a there is a common part of what the
government is doing so we think the
council should be working together but
bear in mind look there's currently tens
of thousands of long-standing Asylum
accommodation places in this country
places that have been in existence for
very many years and are all over the
country as well but the government can't
use any of those Asylum places because
the people who are currently in them
have been waiting for years for a
decision so we should be using those
long-standing Asylum accommodation
places because of course you need Asylum
accommodation for people but that
long-standing accommodation is much
cheaper spread in different places
around the country and the government
can't use it because they're not taking
decisions and that's why it all comes
back to get the government to take
decisions to take them fast do the fast
tracking and actually get this problem
sorted out get a grip and also go after
the criminal gangs who are causing a lot
of these problems in the first place so
you actually prevent the dangerous
Crossings in the first place by working
with France and going after the gangs
final question Yvette Cooper and you're
very passionate about this is your
leaders against armor is passionate
because you know tackling small boats
wasn't even on his
um five-point mission statement that he
came out with a few weeks ago you know
there could be the accusation that you
know labor is soft on migrants because
it wasn't one of his priorities it
seemed
well kirst armor said very clearly you
have to have proper border security
border security National Security and
economic stability those are the things
the foundations on which everything else
is built so that's why we have to
protect our border security and I think
that is what most people want and they
also want a properly controlled and
managed Asylum and Refugee system so
that the UK does our bit alongside other
countries to help those who've fled
persecution and conflict at the moment
we haven't got either of those things we
haven't got proper border security
because they're not going after the
criminal gangs and we certainly haven't
got a properly managed uh Asylum and
Refugee system because that is in chaos
because they're just not getting a grip
Yvette Cooper Shadow Home Secretary good
to have you on the program this
afternoon thank you for your time thank
you